منذ الايام الاولى للحرب تجلت الى اهميه
الاستراتيجيه لمحطه زابوروج النوويه
الاكبر في اوروبا والعاشره على مستوى
العالم فسارعت القوه الروسيه الى اعلان
السيطره الكامله عليها في الرابع من اذار
مارس ظلت رغم ذلك شركه انيرجو اتوم للطاقه
تسير مرافق المحطه
تكررت في محيطها حاله القصف وتبادل الروس
والاوكرانيون الاتهامات بشان ذلك الى ان
قدمت الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا شهر
اغسطس مقترحا طالبتا فيه موسكو باقامه
منطقه منزوعه السلاح حول زبرجها لم يبدا
ضجيج الحرب في محيط المحطه رغم التحذيرات
الدوليه فارسلت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه في بدايه شهر سبتمبر فريق خبراء
على راسه مديرها رافاييل روسي عائلنا
الوضع داخل المحطه واعلن عقب ذلك ان
السلامه الماديه للمنشا تهكت نتيجه تعرضها
لقصف متكرر
اعلنت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بعد
ثلاثه ايام من هذا التصريح ان محطه تزب
روجيه قد فصلت عن اخر خط كان يربطها
بالشبكه الكهربائيه في تطور اللافته
للاحداث داخلها
تطورت الاحداث السريعا من الجانب الروسي
فوقع الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين في الخامس من
اكتوبر مرسوما يقضي بنقل ملكيه محطه الى
بلاده في اعقاب اعلان روسيا ضم اربع
مقاطعه اوكرانيه الى الاتحاد الروسي من
بينها مقاطعه زبرجيا لم تمر ساعات على
صدور القرار الروسي الجديد حتى بدات حشود
القوات الاوكرانيه بالتمركز على محور محطه
زبوجيا وصف الروس حينها التعزيزات
الاوكرانيه على خطوط التماس في المنطقه
بانها الاكبر من نوعها منذ بدا الحرب
عادت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بعد
ذلك للتحذير والتاكيد على ضروره انشاء
منطقه امنه حول المحطه قال مدير الوكاله
يومها ان الاوضاع وصلت الى نقطه يتفق فيها
جميع على ضروره فعل ذلك في اقرب وقت ممكن
في العشرين من نوفمبر اعلنت شركه اينرجو
اتوما الاوكرانيه تعرض منشات البنيه
التحتيه لمحطه زبرجيا للقذف اكثر من اثنتي
عشره مرات خلال يوم واحد ومره اخرى تبادل
الروس والاوكرانيون الاتهامات بشان ذلك
[موسيقى]